I'm David I'm Kevin with that partner
Ben we found a beret oh we make
skateboards from recycled fishnets
collect along the coast of Chile we
needed to figure out how we were gonna
do it basically take something that's
just an idea bring it through the
prototype phase and into the development
phase and continue to grow the first
thing was just kind of struggling with
where is this plastic coming from why
when we go to Australia California
Southeast Asia everywhere you see
plastic in the ocean we knew it needed
to be something where we could take this
commodity this plastic and turn it into
a hobby product and then one thing that
we found that we didn't have any
solutions didn't have a recycling
program was fishing nets there was no
infrastructure in place to dispose the
nets properly so they were damaging the
ecosystem we wanted to show people that
there's value in this discarded material
these nets make up 10% of plastic trash
in the ocean with limited recycling
options it made sense for us to work
with this material we had that aha
moment and said why don't we make a
plastic skateboard we all serve and we
all ski it was our way of expressing our
passion while also creating a solution
to this harmful material the surfing
skating culture because of their outdoor
involvement they can know that by buying
a board that they are making a
difference
crowdfunding enables young innovators to
get projects off the ground a startup
program in Chile give us the opportunity
to take our ideas from Australia to
South America we set up a program to buy
back old fishing nets from the fishermen
the nets are collected transported to
our recycling facility in Santiago
threaded repellant eyes and injection
molded into skate decks this started as
a basic sketch on a napkin from the very
first sketches we went through 50
different versions before we landed on
the one that we all loved you're never
gonna get everything right the first
time nothing goes smoothly and you're
gonna have setbacks and the difference
between success and failure is how you
deal with those and how you move past
them and continue to grow we really
wouldn't be able to do what we've done
so far with Borel
wasn't for what we learn in college
there are so many new tools like
Autodesk available now to help young
designers turning something that exists
on a computer screen into reality
as opposed to just thinking of one giant
problem snow breaking that up into kind
of little pieces when you have a career
that has a passion behind it has a
meaning behind it you're gonna put that
much more energy into it a lot of kids
they feel like they're forced to do
things because that's what you know
maybe an investor's interested in if you
just step back and say okay what am I
good at what am i passionate about
you'll find success as opposed to trying
to walk someone else's back
[Music]